MARK: Hi I'm Mark, and I
want to talk to you about how
you can streamline processes and
simplify your work using Google
Workspace and AppSheet.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Software has made our
day-to-day lives easier.
It gives us immediate access
to any information we need,
food delivered to our
doorsteps, navigation tools
to get us anywhere,
and much more.
But for many, we have yet to
see these types of benefits
at work.
Oftentimes, people
are still tracking
data with pen and paper,
desktop computers,
and archaic disparate
software programs
that make it difficult
to collaborate and get
things done.
That's why we've built Google
Workspace and AppSheet.
With the two platforms,
you have everything
you need to get anything
done all in one place.
First, we have Google Workspace.
Google Workspace helps
you get more done
at work and at home with
communication and collaboration
tools, known and loved
by billions of users,
thoughtfully connected together.
Over time, organizations
start to develop processes.
Think of these as
established steps
or tasks that you regularly
perform as part of your role.
It could be sharing reports,
managing support tickets,
tracking potential candidates,
or holding daily standups.
With AppSheet, you can digitize
and streamline these processes
by combining them
in an intuitive
app with built-in automations.
Take Karina, for example.
Karina is a floor manager
at a production company.
Three times a day, Karina
submits an inspection report
detailing throughput
levels, quality results,
and near misses.
Traditionally, this process
would take Karina 30 minutes
to complete.
She'd have to run the
inspection and write it down
with pen and paper, copy that
information into a spreadsheet,
aggregate that data, and
then copy it into an email,
and send the results.
Utilizing Google
Workspace, Karina
can reduce this process in half.
She runs the inspection on
her mobile device using Forms,
opens up Sheets, and
then copies the data
from there into an email,
and then emails her report.
This works great,
especially if Karina only
had to run an inspection
like this once a month.
But since she's doing
it three times a day,
she decides to streamline
the process even more
by creating an AppSheet app.
Now all she has to do
is run the inspection
using an AppSheet app form
and save the information.
As soon as she
selects Save, the app
updates her Google Sheet
with the new information
and automatically emails
the results to management
using a preformatted
email template
that Karina created in Docs.
Using AppSheet and Google
Workspace for her inspection,
Karina is able to save 20
minutes every inspection, which
is one hour a day
and 20 hours a month.
So how do you go about
creating an AppSheet app?
Well, first set up your data.
Be sure to choose data that is
organized with column headers
and then rows of
data underneath.
Then, if you're in Sheets, you
can click on Tools, AppSheet,
Create an app.
And then AppSheet will
begin reading your data
and setting up your app.
Here, AppSheet has noticed
that we have location data.
So if we look at
the live preview,
we see that it
has already set up
a map view that pinpoints
different locations
in our data.
From here, we can
change our data,
update the user interface, and
set up actions and workflows
so that our app runs
the way we want it,
all without writing a
single line of code.
Google Workspace
and AppSheet give
the people who are
closest to the business
challenges the tools
that they need to create
tailored digital solutions.
By leveraging the two platforms,
you can work faster, smarter,
and more collaboratively
than ever before.
To learn more and to start using
Google Workspace and AppSheet,
click on the link below.
[MUSIC PLAYING]